controlan gran parte de la población del
territorio y de las fronteras pero de
momento la autoridad talibán no tiene
reconocimiento internacional
algo que el secretario general de
naciones unidas pide aprovechar a cambio
de garantías de respeto de los derechos
humanos six very important es muy
importante que todos los miembros del
consejo de seguridad pero en general de
la comunidad internacional estén unidos
para usar el único punto de presión que
existe el interés en talibán a alcanzar
legitimidad y reconocimiento por los
sistemas y misión el talibán es la única
autoridad de facto en afganistán y las
grandes potencias de forma pragmática lo
tratan como tal
china preparaba desde hacía tiempo el
escenario post retirada de las tropas
estadounidenses y le interesa una
relación de buena vecindad con las
autoridades del talibán afgano hamid
[__] ming lado a pesar de que la
situación en afganistán todavía no esté
clara consideramos que el grupo talibán
no repetirá el pasado el talibán tiene
las cosas más claras y es más racional
que la última vez que estuvo en el poder
chancy
afirmó que mantiene su voluntad de
diálogo con todos los actores afganos y
turquía que ayudará al nuevo gobierno en
el terreno internacional en una
entrevista con la cadena ibis y news joe
biden tampoco cerró la puerta al
reconocimiento de un gobierno talibán
crees que talibán ha cambiado y
creo que están en una especie de crisis
existencial sobre si quieren ser
reconocidos por la comunidad
internacional como un gobierno legítimo
y no quiero marcarme no estoy seguro de
que eso quieran en medio de una
creciente represión en afganistán la
comunidad internacional espera que el
talibán cumpla sus promesas de respeto
de los derechos humanos para un eventual
reconocimiento internacional como
gobierno legítimo aunque sean cuales
sean sus acciones nadie podrá negar su
poder tras 20 años de una guerra que
termina como empezó con el talibán
dominando kabul